جائحه خطيره تهدد العالم بعد كورونا وهي
الوباء المعلوماتي مصطلح استحدثته منظمه
الصحه العالميه للتعبير عن المعلومات
الخاطئه التي تنشرها ادوات الذكاء
الاصطناعي على الانترنت المنظمه شكلت
سابقا فريقا يعمل مع شركات محركات البحث
وشبكات التواصل لمواجهه انتشار الاشاعات
حول كورونا لكن الامر لم يتوقف فرئيس
المنظمه قال ان اقليه صغيره تصدر معلومات
مضلله وتتلاعب عمدا بالوقائع مختصون قالوا
ايضا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمتلك عوامل
مساهمه في التضليل بحيث يمكن لاحدهم صياغه
خبر كاذب بطريقه دراماتيكيه في المقابل
نصح باحثون المستخدمين بالتركيز على صياغه
الاخبار اذ ان الرسائل المضلله تعتمد
عناوين مشابهه مثل لا يريدونك ان تعرف
الحقيقه كما اوصوا بالبحث في المصادر
الطبيه الموثوقه عن المعلومه وعدم
مشاركتها قبل التاكد من مصداقيتها